press our political editor Beth Rick B
is here with me and best speculation
about who's going to be in that cabinet
well if we look down the far end of the
street look at some of those supporters
there I can certainly see Ben Wallace
the defense secretary now he's not
turning up here to be sacked is he well
we still expect him to be defense
secretary but I have to say though there
are a lot of MPS down there on dozens of
MPS I think that is a bigger crowd than
Boris Johnson had this morning but it's
the symbolism of that actually uh
because this is
a prime minister who did not win the
support initially of the MPS Rishi sunak
won with the Parliamentary ballot she in
the end had slightly more backing than
he did but you would expect that because
it was so nailed on that she would win
and then in terms of the vote from the
members of the party if the polls were
right
her lead narrowed quite substantially
over the course of the race between her
and Rishi Sonic in the end she picked up
57 he picked up 43. it started out that
she was at 66 67 so you could argue if
the polling was right that the more the
party saw of her the less sure they were
for her to be prime minister so I think
that part of having all of those MPS
there to come and cheer her will be to
try and show that this is a United
conservative party that it is moving on
and it's getting on with the task and
when she gave that very short speech
yesterday acceptance speech it was
delivered delivered deliver and in terms
of what Adam was saying about will she
change the tone as she addresses the
nation I spoke to one of her key allies
last night and I said what's the speech
going to be like is it going to be
different and this person said to me I
think it'll be pretty much what she said
yesterday she is consistent in her
message she doesn't Wax and Wane if you
like so let's see if if it's about
delivery delivery delivery is the sort
of Mantra that she wanted to get across
and why because there was a sense wasn't
there amongst MPS of the frustration at
the lack of delivery from the Johnson
government in the last months and it was
so embroiled with the scandals of some
of the behaviors within Downing Street
that it just wasn't getting on with the
job of governing the country so the
whole Mantra will be delivery and I can
just see Dermot um behind us just down
the street Nadine zahawi has now come
out he is the current Chancellor could
be going to Cabinet office he's just
talking there to Ben Wallace and I think
I might be able to see James cleverly
there as Adam was saying he is expected
to be the foreign secretary swella
bravaman expected to be the Home
Secretary Jacob Reese morgue is expected
to be the business secretary you can see
him
he is a key uh friend of Liz truss
actually they did a lot of work in in
the past uh together on the back benches
and there's some talk that he might
become the Northern Ireland sector of
State there was taught that sabji Javid
uh the former Health sector might take
that job but that doesn't seem to be
happening uh perhaps he like he and
Duncan Smith didn't want the role Jacob
re-smog I can just see uh he's going to
come behind your screen a bit in a
moment he's he's coming up and isn't
that a big crowd of of MPC you see Jacob
just coming into shot there and Marie
trevelyn in the fuchsia suit she is
going to have a role she's a former
trade secretary
um she will be expected to take a
cabinet position as well so they are all
getting ready uh to cheer on Liz truss
when she arrives in down the street and
as I said that is a pretty sizable group
of MPS you might almost forget that show
only one support of 42 percent of her
parliamentary party that's 149 MPS out
of 300 quite a few more then during the
course of the campaign
tell me about tell me about um
the style and and the way she delivers a
speech I mean it's going to be quite a
contrast with just nine hours ago that
is quite an act to follow in terms of
Boris Johnson you know jokes about being
a a rocket booster hopping around on a
space Hopper Dylan the dog was in there
Larry the cat ancient Roman Statesman
that's not Liz truss his style it's not
Liz truss's style and actually it was
interesting wasn't it that during the
hostins she actually turned some of her
sometimes slightly jilted performances
slightly um into an advantage if you
like she she played into it she said I'm
not a slick performer but what you see
is what you get taking a dig if you like
at Rishi sunak who is a very good media
performer and a very good communicator
um you know Liz trust isn't as slick as
that but she has improved I think
tremendously uh during the hustins in
her delivery of speeches but no it's a
very different style uh to Boris Johnson
it's short it's sharp it's decisive it
she sometimes shoots from the hip though
and she can trip herself up you saw that
when she was foreign secretary and she
talked about uh foreign Fighters going
over to Ukraine and she had to reverse
uh that position pretty quickly
well uh that speech expected we thought
sometime between four and five o'clock
but we can work it out ourselves
watching the progress of her car and uh
the outriders and the police support and
her team it's making pretty slow
progress in actual fact through London
still to the west of London we
understand those of you that know the
geography somewhere just past Shepherd's
Bush so do the math still away to go
it's 20 to five that speech perhaps not
taking place for the next half an hour
or so we'll have it all for you live do
you want Mr thing right here on Sky News
so the the cars we think are going to
start arriving fairly shortly but um
once she's in place then that speech
will take place best hearing something
well the thing I was going to say to you
is I think she is going to be arriving
quite shortly and that's why everyone's
Gathering but I think also what we're
going to see is quite a rapid cabinet
you know sometimes it goes on for hours
because someone goes in did the
negotiation doesn't work and they take a
while and then it all falls apart and it
can go on for hours and hours this time
the cabinet I think is nailed on I think
it's all been sorted out and I think
that they will be perhaps walking up the
street but they're going to be in and
out pretty quickly in those
announcements I think will be made
pretty succinctly part of that German uh
some of her team told me was about
trying to show that she is ready for
business she wants to get straight to it
she needs to get on with the job of
trying to sort out the energy crisis and
give the public some reassurance because
it has been an effective zombie
government hasn't it for weeks with the
conservative party instead of dealing
with these massive policy issues uh
fighting a leadership contest I should
say too though Dermot that Nadeem Sahari
her Chancellor that could go to run the
cabinet office and quasi-kartang her
business secretary that is expected to
go and be Chancellor have been working
up all the options so the work for what
this energy package might look like has
been going on but for the public it's
clearly been frustrating you can look at
recent polling one poll uh put the
conservative 17 percentage points uh
behind labor and polls have regularly
put them double digits behind so in
terms of the public view they've taken
quite a dim view of what's been
happening lately uh in the conservative
party and in the conservative government
do you know what just to update people
on the weather I think that lectern may
be going back inside Downey Street it is
just starting to terrain here in Downing
Street don't know how long this shower
is going to last we shall see let's talk
again to Adam Bolton now for my
political editor now political uh
commentator and Adam just picking up
there on the on the difference in style
and that's drift and it was more than
drift that we've had for for two months
we are now going to see frenetic
activity from government
yes I think we are and we're also going
to see uh action on the international
stage it's noticeable that uh the new
prime minister has been receiving uh
messages of congratulations from other
leaders all of them very much uh sort of
holding out an olive branch who had one
from the Irish one from the French and
others although apparently someone
called Liz Trussell who has a hashtag at
Liz truss has been receiving a lot of
messages from foreign leaders on Twitter
as well uh because they think they're
communicating with the Prime Minister
and they are but but she is most likely
going to be going to Dublin fairly soon
she is likely to attend the United
Nations General Assembly uh in
mid-september now there would probably
be her first meeting with President Joe
Biden maybe in a relatively brief brush
but I have to remember that Boris
Johnson actually while he was prime
minister only had one face-to-face
meeting uh with Joe Biden and and there
is uh later in the year an international
Summit in Bali as well of the G20 so uh
I think what we'll quite often see with
a new leader is they will want to the
other foreign leaders and foreign
diplomats will want to get her measure
they didn't really need to do that with
Boris Johnson because he was a familiar
uh National figure by the time he became
prime minister and indeed had already
made quite a lot of enemies in Brussels
in particular where he'd been a
correspondent for the Daily Telegraph
but Liz truss they are showing
themselves at this stage to be rather
more open and she has said that she
plans to take rather fewer Prime
ministerial photo ops uh perhaps because
she's been teased for the photographs
she's taken during the campaign that
she's going to make fewer visits fewer
appearances on camera as prime minister
than her previous processor that will be
very much a change in style one thing I
think we're seeing since we have to
spend so much time looking at the
lectins where the prime minister's
speaking are we seeing a new design of
lectern with that sort of twirly spiral
uh design which she spoke at yesterday
election like that with the Union flag
sort of uh built into the sides that one
today just seems to be pure wood but
quite often believe it or not a lot of
thought goes into what sort of lectern
the Prime Minister should appear at
perhaps we've seen it before I certainly
haven't seen one with that spirally
Arrangement previously although we've
got used to seeing the prime ministerial
seal on
various lectins of different kinds we're
talking lectins
allowed to approach it and test out your
theory that um that's made of wood as
well I'm also thinking there's some
going to be a spare lectin erected
somewhere inside Downing Street because
it has started tipping down now and I
can't imagine the new prime minister
will want to make her speech in a
downpour we'll see if that abates
because we are tell the thinking is that
list trusts the new prime minister is 15
minutes away or so from number 10
Downing streets and therefore we'll need
a few minutes I imagine to greet our
supporters before she makes that speech
stay with us though right here on Sky
News we're staying live on it you won't
miss a thing uh involving the journey
and of course what Liz truss is going to
say herself our political editor Beth
Rigby is here with me and so much on her
plate Beth I was interested in what you
said hearing from her supporters earlier
on that she is going to prioritize this
phrase sequencing so we know number one
there are things that we have been
talking about that we're not talking
about at the moment which are certain to
come back I'm talking first and foremost
about the the NHS Kobe hasn't gone away
the NHS is in difficulties anyway and
she's got this issue of funding she
apparently has pledged to take some
money away from the NHS and there's been
such a focus on energy bills
um that this hasn't been discussed but I
was talking to Paul Johnson of the ifs I
have to say loudmonia and the sky is
open the skies have opened and Liz
truss's team uh are all standing outside
number 11 now getting absolutely
trenched they do have Rollies
um but you have to wonder whether Liz
truss uh will uh be doing the speech
outside on the left they've covered the
lectern actually with a plastic bag ever
Innovative uh there I've lost my train
of thought there's not an official
lectin cover
of the ifs about this about budgets
because when the spending review set
budgets NHS and all the public services
and schools inflation was predicted or
running at three percent
so there will be an issue about spending
in the NHS and schools over the Autumn
anyway because uh departments will be
saying we need more money because
inflation is eating up the budgets for
schools and hospitals around the country
just to give you some context about the
pressure the NHS is under one in eight
britons are now on waiting lists for
appointments one in eight people can't
get GP appointments ambulances are
having record high weights as record
high weights for a e it's a huge problem
now the Liz trust viewers that you can
make the NHS more efficient
and then you can improve service she's
put in as I said her key Lieutenant an
ally and problem solve if you like of
government uh to raise coffee probably
into the health brief uh putting someone
she really trusts to try and fix that
and putting quasiquartering into the
chancellorship and Jacob Reese Mark
another key Ally who agrees with her I
think on economic principles uh into the
biz Department to try and fix the two
most pressing issues I think the other
issue that will be uh key for her is
immigration and the problem of small
boats and the Rwanda scheme which was
meant to solve this problem clearly
hasn't got up and running and in terms
of what Adam was talking about about
looking at the European Convention of
Human Rights and some of those issues
how much will she press reform in order
to try and drive through that
immigration policy which we know is
popular with conservative of Voters so
so watch for that as well that could be
a combination of sowella bravaman in the
home office and another key Allied
Brandon Lewis who I think potentially
will go to the justice department just
staying with the economy and that very
important point you make Beth about the
effect of inflation we've seen it
already in terms of the industrial
action the strikes that have been taking
place inflation predicted by some
reputable economists who perhaps hit 20
22 percent that's eroding real wages we
all know that those staff working in the
NHS already Under Pressure nurses
talking about going on strike however
much they get it's not going to be
enough to compensate for that the rain
beginning to really tip down again the
impromptu the makeshift cover going back
on the lectin but it all gives that
sense particularly the industrial action
the railways the docks we've seen and
more to come that somehow the country
isn't working Britain is broken
the issue of inflation and the way it's
eroding
um household incomes uh is and also
wages is a key problem uh this winter
and I think there will be issues I'm
just watching dirt actually the elective
yes it's been it's being Retreat Retreat
it's retreating it's retreating but
actually
um
I have to say in his trusses team is
also uh getting absence absolutely
throwing it down isn't it they're
getting absolute judged uh I would say
uh dermit that the new prime minister
will not want to give her an organ
address in the pouring rain it will be
um an analogy that she will not like
well you know like a like a bride in a
wedding perhaps you might make another
circuit because these are short sharp
showers
wouldn't really want to arrive in Downey
Street and get out of the car in this no
no uh she will absolutely will not want
to do that it's absolutely throwing it
down I believe it is
um it is really funny but going back to
what you were saying about
um inflation
there is an issue about public sector
pay as we know and not only does she
have the issues of energy bills of
funding the NHS of schools and all those
pressures she also has the issue of
public sector pay and the threat of
strike action not just from transport
workers that we've seen but now we're
seeing barristers go on strike teachers
are balloting the NHS workers are
balloting uh you know if Britain goes
into a situation over the Autumn into
winter where public services are just
shutting down because people are so fed
up about these these effective wage Cuts
because of sawing inflation that is
another huge problem uh for the Prime
Minister I mean the intro keeps when you
look at the intro the problems just seem
to be piling up so you have to deal with
them in order of importance and that
leads us right the way back to the issue
of energy Here's a thought for you Beth
it has been mentioned before but if it
lands well but the economic prospects
certainly the price of energy looks like
it's still going to continue Rising it's
taking a huge amount of money to fund
that but if it lands well what about an
early election an election next year the
fast and I save it lands well it buys
her time and it could potentially give
her a poll bounce and you're right at
that point does she decide to go for it
I should just tell you
um her team are going in and I'm just
hearing that we will do the speech
inside so all our supporters are there
but the rain is driving and uh her team
uh her number 11 team have just gone
back in and as I understand it she's
going to do the speeching side which is
a shame because there's nothing better
than seeing a prime minister outside
number 10 she had her supporters ready
to come but I think can you see the MPS
also now all dispersing
um a change of plan uh it would not be
um what Liz trust would want to give the
inaugural boots in the driving Reign uh
that is not
um
the look no certainly not so we're
expecting at this point although as I
say these are short and sharp but just
because this one stops doesn't mean to
say another one isn't going to follow
shortly after so we're expecting that
speech now to take place indoor says the
reception committee rapidly disperse and
on the left-hand side of your screen the
uh Entourage the list trust Convoy makes
its way rather slowly through some of
the back Streets of London to arrive
here in Downing Street well just a
thought about the outgoing or sorry the
gone prime minister back bencher Boris
Johnson what do you think he's going to
do and uh is he really going to be able
to bite his lip for months to come
well he hasn't completely ruled out a
return
um
Eddie Lister his former Chief of Staff
and old Ally said never rule it out uh
but what he did say today was that he
was going to go back to the back benches
he used more colorful language uh than
that of course
um and that he will support Liz truss
look there's lots of options for Boris
Johnson uh the first one of course will
be to go on the speaker circuit where he
uh will no doubt command uh huge sums of
money to give speeches around the world
it's something that David Cameron and
Theresa May did also will he return to
writing a column in one of the big
newspapers he used to be as you know a
telegraph uh columnist but he will still
be he feels hard done by though doesn't
he I mean we heard it in that speech
they changed the rules Midway he said
and there's never been an admission from
him of doing anything wrong no that
speech
um was laced with
recrimination and a sense of indignation
I think there was no acknowledgment of
any shortcomings personal failings on
the path of Boris Johnson
um that might have
um precipitated his own downfall and he
certainly felt that he was hard done by
by his parliamentary party he made that
quite clear there is some talk among
some Boris Johnson supporters that if it
all goes terribly wrong with Liz truss
may they you know try and get him back
but I think you know it's hard to see
that now although I've learned to
predict nothing in politics academic
um but for now we go back to the benches
and insist he'll be loyal to this trust
and you should remember too that um he
was her she was his choice he didn't
publicly say it but the fact that his
key allies fell in behind Liz tras
um the fact that the party membership a
core of whom were very loyal to him fell
in behind this trust he did help if you
like
determine the outcome of this contest
between Rishi sanak one of Richardson's
supporters during the contest said that
Boris Johnson's support of Liz truss had
been the poison pill in Sonic's attempts
to enter number 10. so he is Lord her
but you know you saw a slight division
between them didn't you on the issue of
fracking when Liz trust said that she
would introduce fracking and then he
made a speech uh disagreeing with that
so let's see
um let's see whether as time goes on
there are more splits between them he
she won't want him to be the small to
her on the back benches I mean every
time
Theresa May did that to Boyce Johnson it
was extremely unhelpful but Liz trust
and Boyce Johnson certainly have a
better relationship than Theresa May and
boy responsive I should just say she's
getting closer much much closer I think
that's um stops raining again yeah and
some of the MPS are coming out so I
don't know maybe it's like
um one of those clocks isn't it one of
those Swiss clocks where you come in and
out um but as I say there could be
another shower following hard on the
heels of this one yes some this trusts
is getting very close
okay but it was short short sharp
um just on by chance again but you know
might that option I mean he's going to
remain as an MP at the moment might that
option they'll be taken away from him
because there is still that
parliamentary committee looking into
whether he misled Parliament now if they
find against him that ultimately could
cost him his seat couldn't it yes and
there's been a big there's been a big
kind of pushback hasn't there in the
final days of his Premiership to try and
push back against that inquiry to try
and undermine the legitimacy of that
inquiry
um but you are right that that is still
a very live issue for Boris Johnson of
course it has far less Jeopardy when
you're a back bench MP to when you're
prime minister
and it is approaching five o'clock and
uh let's use the word approaching that's
the embankment By The River Thames as
list truss is making her way and yes
indeed the lectins back out in out shake
it all about I wonder if they've
shaking the rain off it maybe got a bit
of a better cover for it they are going
to to make that speech that it's a set
piece as you were saying Beth you you
want to see the Prime Minister there the
new prime minister she may not have won
a general election she won an election
and they're all back out again do you
think some of them have got two jackets
in there they're all still very dry
they're all back they're all bucks Ray's
coffee has just come out uh Wendy Morton
though another MP I think she might
become the chief work she's out and the
uh trust team are all back out and
they're in good spirits they're a little
bit drenched actually to be honest
um they didn't have as big on they'd
have Big Sky News umbrellas like we did
but all the MPS are back as well and
look of course she wants to stand and
face uh the world's media you can't see
on the screens what we can see but there
are literally hundreds of cameraman of
cameras of news organization the whole
world is watching uh this moment of uh
Liz trust for coming the 56th prime
minister of the United Kingdom and the
third uh female prime minister all of
them have been conservatives I should
say when it comes to electing a female
as their leader interesting that though
um and to continue in that vein because
we do know I mean it would be a real
shock if it's the top four as we
understand it in cabinet prime minister
foreign secretary Chancellor Home
Secretary if they aren't who we think
they are going to be no white men not a
single white man amongst the top four
that is history
it is history yeah
um and only a few years ago when David
Cameron was
um prime minister there was a lot of
talk about the lack of diversity at the
top table and uh the need for more
female MPS in Parliament and the need
for more female MPS in cabinet and yes
that is quite a change and it is a big
moment
do you think that's going to be
reflected then throughout cabinets and
throughout the ministerial ranks
before with the ministerial ranks is how
she tries to blend the party or whether
she does or doesn't that
when Boris Johnson won in 2019 every
single person that had back Jeremy Hunt
was literally kicked out of government
his prime desire was slavish loyalty and
he did not want anyone even in
ministerial positions that were not a
hundred percent in team Boris and that
is sort of part of the issue that for
grievances from him that simmered on the
back benches and then began to blow up
when things got tough for him and I were
really interested to see how she tries
to blend her cabinet and her ministerial
team now one of her allies said to me
the other day Liz truss will want
loyalty with key staff with key cabinet
positions she'll need people that are
signed up a hundred percent to her
agenda but she also recognizes there's
an awful lot to do in the run-up to the
next general election if she doesn't
call one earlier than 2024 to try and
win over a public that quite frankly at
the moment are moving towards labor in
terms of voting intention okay and she
says they need competence and they need
to be competent Minister just want to
get to the imminent arrival because some
I'm familiar with that route more often
certainly not by helicopter more often
on my bicycle on the on the blue routes
there but um she is just actually
Crossing away from Westminster I think
to come in perhaps over Westminster
bridge I
think that's Lambeth Bridge
um Coming certainly very close to
Westminster yes that is Lambeth Bridge
she'll turn left there her Entourage
will turn left there along a different
side of the environment come back over
Westminster bridge and then right into
White Hall and into Downing Street
itself uh three or four minutes away at
the very least just Mark our card before
we hear it about that speech length
content
in terms of the length the one yesterday
was really short I don't imagine that
she will be speaking for a long time but
I think the content will be I am here I
will deliver uh for the country the best
days are ahead of us that's something
she's consistently said uh when she was
in the hostage she will talk about
energy she will tell the public that
she's heard them uh she will talk about
the NHS I suspect she will basically try
and touch on some of the issues that she
knows she has to deal with that are the
biggest pressures for her and perhaps
people are most concerned about the
thing I don't know though I'd be
interested here is what does she say
about Boris Johnson because she used him
like yesterday she praised him publicly
to the party whilst completely ignoring
uh Rishi sunak but she praised her
predecessor will she do that on the
lectum to the nation or will she just
quietly consign uh the Boris Johnson era
uh to history and try and present
herself as a new prime minister a new
Pro a new Administration a new era of
course it's a new Administration but the
conservatives have been in power for 12
years and part of the more Curious
elements of listening to Liz truss and
Rishi sunak talk about the country in
the past few weeks and policies and
what's been right and what's gone wrong
has been the more most disavowing the
record of previous conservative Prime
Ministers so let's see what she says
about Boris Johnson she has to in a way
create a sense of new momentum and
freshness rather than continuity because
of course sadly something as you point
out there that Boris Johnson himself did
pull off of course brexit was a big
factor in that but almost a complete
break with the May and certainly the
Cameron years
yeah and the thing about Liz truss and
some of her detractors in Parliament
some of the senior MPS I talked to is
that their concern they say is that she
is continuity Boris Johnson and if she
doesn't
make up the cabinet differently run
government differently in which she's
more Collegiate and she takes uh more
advice and she's more transparent and
communicates more with backbenchers that
that continuity Boris Johnson Style of
approach will not bode well for her with
a party that clearly wanted Boris
Johnson to leave I mean 60 members of
his government resigned uh in protest to
try and force him out so I mean someone
said to me uh in July that she was
continuity Boris Johnson but without the
charm that's quite a criticism of Liz
truss I think but that's that's what
some of them are concerned about that
she will be more of the same and it's
not what the public it's not what the
public will want
and here it comes Liz truss is
approaching the gates of Downey Street
the supporters all out here the rain has
stopped they are gambling it doesn't
return if it does we're not talking
about a few spitting spots it is
absolute steroids but as we were
discussing Beth there a new prime
minister any new Prime Minister elected
under whatever circumstances wants to
make that speech outside in front of
that famous lacquered black door and set
out her stall for the next difficult
well two years that's what she says
before the next general election well
it's going to be a difficult two days to
say the the very least we await the
arrival of Liz truss you'll soon hear
her supporters they're turning into
Downing Street now let's just soak up
the atmosphere
thank you
[Music]
a freshly appointed new prime minister
Liz truss third prime minister in just
over three years
let's listen to her
[Applause]
noon
I have just
accept Her Majesty the Queens
kind invitation to form a new government
let me pay tribute to my predecessor
Boris Johnson delivered brexit the
covert vaccine and stood up to Russian
aggression
history will see him as a hugely
consequential prime minister
I'm honored to take on this
responsibility at a vital time for our
country
what makes the United Kingdom great is
our fundamental belief in Freedom in
Enterprise and in fair play
our people have shown grit courage and
determination time and time again
we now face severe Global headwinds
caused by Russia's appalling war in
Ukraine and the aftermath of covert
now is the time to tackle the issues
that are holding Britain back
we need to build roads homes and
Broadband faster
we need more investment and great jobs
in every town and city across our
country
we need to reduce the burden on families
and help people get on in life
I know that we have what it takes to
tackle those challenges
of course it won't be easy but we can do
it
we will transform Britain into an
aspiration Nation with high paying jobs
Safe Streets and where everyone
everywhere has the opportunities they
deserve
I will take action this day an action
every day to make it happen
United with our allies we will stand up
for freedom and democracy around the
world
recognizing that we can't have security
at home without having security abroad
as prime minister I will pursue three
early priorities
firstly I will get Britain working again
I have a bold plan to grow the economy
through tax cuts and reform
I will cut taxes to reward hard work and
boost business-led growth and investment
I will drive reform in my mission to get
the United Kingdom working building and
growing
we'll get Spades in the ground to make
sure people are not facing unaffordable
energy bills and we will also make sure
that we are building hospitals schools
roads a broadband
secondly I will deal Hands-On with the
energy crisis caused by Putin's War I
will take action this week to deal with
energy bills and to secure our future
energy Supply
thirdly I will make sure that people can
get doctors appointments and the NHS
Services they need we will put our
Health Service on a firm footing
by delivering on the economy on energy
and on the NHS we will put our nation on
the path to long-term success
we shouldn't be daunted by the
challenges we face
as strong as the storm may be I know
that the British people are stronger
our country was built by people who get
things done
we have huge reserves of talent of
energy and determination
I am confident that together we can ride
out the storm
we can rebuild our economy and we can
become the modern brilliant Britain that
I know we can be
this is our Vital mission to ensure
opportunity and prosperity for all
people and future Generations I am
determined to deliver
thank you
let's trust having just taken over from
Boris Johnson
posing outside the famous black door
with a husband
[Applause]
action this day
Minister do you have a plan
[Applause]
so battery be our political editor is
with me here as I was saying there Beth
we heard from let's trust that action
this day and every day laying out a
stall there priority number one there is
this cost of living crisis what do we
hear about that she would take action
this week look it was a workman-like
speech uh it was short it was sharp as I
thought it might be uh analyst trust uh
making uh three pledges to the British
people fastly on the economy uh she said
that she would cut taxes so still
talking about the tax cuts and reform uh
the economy and what she means by that
is she wants to deregulate and what I
mean by that is she uh wants to do
supply side reforms uh she'll look at
potentially workers right she'll look at
uh regulations on companies she wants to
boost growth and investment but name
checking again those tax cuts so let's
see uh what she does uh with that and
then of course uh she said the NHS is
her second priority oh sorry then sorry
she said that the dealing with the
energy crisis was her second priority
she would take action this week she said
to deal with energy bills and secure
Supply and what we are going to get is a
combination of an immediate package to
help with bills over the winter and then
a longer term plan about how to secure
energy Supply that will be changing some
of the market contracts with suppliers
uh to try and cut bills but that won't
happen until a year 18 months out it
will be about securing more Renewables
but it will also be about oil and gas uh
licenses using oil and gas in the short
term to secure energy supplies economy
transitions to Renewables now I'm told
that the net Green net zero Target by
2050 stands but uh put it this way one
of her key allies said oil and gas
produces and production will not be
demonized by this government some more
green Tories might not like that we
don't bet talk to me about what she was
greeted by in there of course Downing
Street staff we saw all her supporters
go back inside but it really is straight
to work the announcements are going to
flow from now on in well I say we're
going to find out who's going to be
around that cabinet table it's going to
flow we're going to get the cabinet
quite quickly the top positions because
they've all been decided but look
Diamond also she is not massively known
with the public the conservatives are
polling badly and they she has some
severe crises that she has to deal with
energy bills and then she name checked
it her third priority the NHS and if she
doesn't get this stuff sorted quickly
then she loses her window with the
public now normally typically a new
prime minister might get a honeymoon
bounce Teresa may got one she called an
election didn't go to plan done but
normally a prime minister might expect a
honeymoon bounce as they they enter uh
number 10 and introduce new policies and
new spending plans but for Liz trust
she's entering with crises just prices
that she has to deal with the Fasteners
she said this week we expect on Thursday
will be the energy issue but then she
has to sort out the NHS issues because
if she doesn't sort out the NHS issues I
think conservative MPS agree that the
public will not want to support the
conservatives at the next general
election just tell me about that energy
announcements I mean it's going to be so
big it's so important to everything
about the Liz truss project and she's
addressing not just the British people
their hopes and aspirations
International money markets going to be
looking at the precise figures given how
big they are going to be do you really
think it will be as soon as this
Thursday be course it is so large you
have to get it right you have one shot I
think
exactly what they're going to announce
on Thursday and I was told you know in
the early hours of yesterday morning by
some of her team and people around her
that they haven't finalized the plan
they're still working it through just to
get in there to to get her feet under
the desk
but what we'll get is a sense of what
the plan is and then it will be fleshed
out as I was saying in a mini budget
later this month but you are right these
things are Market sensitive because they
move the markets which is why this stuff
has to be held so closely I think the
issue is and you've hit it on the head
there is a narrow path through which she
can deal with energy bills and reassure
on her longer term economic plans when
she talks about cutting taxes because if
you are going to borrow which you'll
have to do tens and tens of billions of
pounds to fund energy support for
businesses and households and then you
also say you are going to cut taxes
investors get a bit worried about the
value of the currency they might have
invested in the value of the debt that
they might have invested in and what you
do not want to do is get the markets
jittery I was speaking to someone
familiar with the treasury about this
the other day and I said is this a
pathway to a real economic shop in the
country how worried are you about that
as a prospect and this person said to me
delivers trust can do some temporary
short-term borrowing plans almost like
the covid emergency loans and the
furlough scheme but make sure that that
is a temporary borrowing with a more
thick credible longer term plan for the
economy
but they might be able to solve that to
investors and the markets but of course
this stuff has to be got right and it is
going to be a big challenge for her to
marry up both of those things and as I
said the tax carts she does want to cut
taxes she believes that that will grow
the economy which we know is facing a
protracted recession if you believe what
the bank of England says I mean
so she thinks that that tax cuts will
promote economic growth
but many economists would disagree with
her and would say you think it's the
wrong approach and that of course is
what Richard said he said don't cut
taxes now until you've got inflation
under control because borrowing can just
Stoke inflation and that has a knock-on
effect for The Wider economy and uh Beth
do you think the treasury experience in
terms of getting this right a detail and
the stress testing you have to do we
know how long it takes to do a plain
ordinary budget so to speak she has
treasury experience of course she saw it
as a demotion at the time by Theresa May
do you think that will will help
how treasure experience yeah I think Liz
trust just the argument within uh her
cam is that treasury Orthodoxy as they
put it that you don't cut taxes and
borrow to grow
um they think that that is the wrong
approach and she wants to try a
different approach and when I talk to
some conservative MPS the reason they
backed her is because they think they
need a radical approach to try and shift
the economy now many economists would
say it's all very well to talk about
long-term growth but that can't happen
you can't turn the switch and it comes
overnight it takes years and years and
years for those supply side reforms as
they uh would call them to to feed
through into the economy but again I'm
I'm interested to see about the
sequencing of the announcements because
the tax cuts she might do them
immediately she might not it just
depends on what the books look like and
what they think the markets will bear
okay Beth many thanks indeed for the
time being our political Beth Rigby
there with her assessment of the the
tasks ahead the challenges ahead for Liz
trussas prime minister let's just talk
about some of the international
reactions some of it came in yesterday
after Liz truss was appointed leader of
the conservative party of course it's
only today after her audience with the
Majesty of the queen that she has become
Prime Minister we were waiting to hear
from the United States we now have
President Biden has tweeted saying
congratulations to prime minister Liz
truss I look forward to deepening the
special relationship there those words
mentioned between our countries and
working in close cooperation on global
challenges including continued support
for Ukraine as it defends itself against
Russian aggression I want to talk now to
Adam Bolton political commentator of
course former political editor here with
us at Sky News and let's talk about
those international relations now that
we've heard from the White House Adam
and we know they have deep reservation
questions about Downing Street's
approach when Boris Johnson was there
and of course Liz truss's approach
because she was in charge of those
negotiations with the EU over the
Northern Ireland protocol we know the
reservations that Joe Biden has about
that we also know about what this trust
said about President macron of France
while she was campaigning for the
leadership she has got some bridges to
rebuild
well she has but not nearly as many
bridges as Boris Johnson of course had
as far as his relations with
International leaders it was pretty
clear he only had one meeting three
years
with Joe Biden that the two of them did
not see eye to eye and the Irish issue
was very much an issue for an
irish-american president now what's
interesting is that on the whole
question of the protocol
it does seem as if there's been quite a
lot of work going on between officials
in Ireland in the EU and in the UK ahead
of this change of prime minister we do
think that Liz truss will probably go to
Ireland fairly soon and certainly people
who've been uh close to this have been
telling me that they do think there's a
window of opportunity for a settlement
in that area and that certainly would
cheer Joe Biden as would an early
demonstration from Liz truss which I
think we're pretty certain we're going
to get uh that the United Kingdom is
going to continue in its very tough
stance against Ukraine and in support of
Ukraine against President Putin now uh
let's just uh have a quick recap on what
Liz truss actually said when she came
into Downing Street because this was her
first address to the nation it was also
of course just after the queen had uh
kissed hands with her 15th prime
minister and it was interesting I think
first of all in terms of style very
plain Jane No Frills at all no reference
to the fact that she must have known
that her audience had been standing in
the rain for some time she got straight
into it very brief tribute to Boris
Johnson saying that his achievements in
her view were brexit dealing with kovid
and Ukraine then she talked about the
headwinds facing Britain mentioning
particularly the the Ukraine conflict
she didn't go into the consequences of
brexit no surprise there and talked
about the issues which are holding
Britain back and it's very interesting
after 12 years and four conservative
prime ministers the incoming
conservative prime minister is still
talking about the things that are
holding Britain back and
um probably in the lamest bit of the
speech she talked about turning Britain
into an aspiration Nation well frankly
uh that kind of alliteration is uh
padding we've heard so many times before
then she got down to her key pledges she
said she's going to get Britain working
again she promised tax cuts and reform
and talked particularly about housing
said she was going to get Spades in the
ground but also said she was going to
get Spades in the ground with reference
to unaffordable energy so that seemed to
me a nod that she she's going to try and
press ahead not only with expanding oil
production in the oil and gas production
in the North Sea but also with fracking
that could be fairly controversial she
then promised that within a week she's
going to have a package to deal with the
energy crisis and then interestingly she
focused on the NHS saying that she would
make sure that everyone could get a
doctor's appointment which frankly
doesn't sound like a particularly
inspiring aspiration for an incoming
prime minister but a lot of people are
having real difficulties and then
finally this promise to rebuild our
economy now Liz truss then went into
Downing Street she will have been
clapped in by the staff and by her
supporters I think we'll get pictures of
that then she'll be taken into the
cabinet room and briefed by the cabinet
secretary and briefed by some things of
security and then of course the thing
which we're all waiting for is to see
whether she announces her full cabinet
this evening quite possibly even having
a cabinet meeting although has to be
said things have been running a little
bit behind the given schedule let's go
now back to Downing Street and Mark
Austin mark
yup thanks very much uh indeed Adam so
Liz truss is set to get straight down uh
to business after becoming the UK's new
prime minister she was expected to give
her maiden speech uh any moment uh well
she was expected uh to give it but it
was delayed by the weather and tonight
as Adam Bolton was saying she will start
appointing her cabinet top of the agenda
of course for that cabinet tackling the
cost of living and helping vulnerable
households uh through the winter energy
crisis well I'm joined now by the
conservative MP Paul Scully who
supported uh Liz truss's campaign thanks
very much indeed for being with us uh
two things struck me she said it
wouldn't be easy which it won't and the
other thing that struck me is how much
money she seems to be spending in the
early period of her Premiership
well it's slowly not going to be easy we
know that and that's why she's right to
you know not be quoting Saint Francis of
Assisi or anything there's not a moment
for that it's a moment I'm actually
saying here are the bullet points of
what uh people expect from her and our
government and uh that she is going to
deliver and clearly when you are looking
at the uh situation as you've been
describing you and other commentators
have been describing this afternoon the
scale of it clearly we've got to um you
know make sure that we can support
individuals and businesses to um if
we're going to have get to that long
term strategy of growing the economy
showing entrepreneurship and uh
increasing and energy Supply
right and uh could you confirm she's
going to
um introduce this uh freeze uh on uh
energy the cap on energy at around 2 500
pounds is that what your understanding
is I can't I can't confirm that either
way to be fair it's not my you know I've
been working with local government
making sure that we get the current
support out to people
um so we'll have to wait for that
announcement so I can't add anything to
that I'm afraid but clearly that but it
signifies action it does signify the
scale of the situation that we that
we're facing that we need to deliver
but she spoke in a speech about helping
people with their energy bills she then
went on to speak about uh the NHS and
how they would be spending for that and
obviously Boris Johnson has committed to
this uh
um defense spending three percent which
um Liz truss is also saying she's going
to stick with I mean this is an awful
lot of government spending something's
got to give hasn't it and could that be
tax cuts I think what we what we'll see
is we're delivering we're not starting
with a blank sheet we've got a 29 uh
2019 Manifesto to on which to deliver
and so there's a lot of these things a
lot of these things are already factored
in to the uh treasury uh forecast but
clearly this extra uh situation and cost
of living when you're kickstarting the
uh the the global economy and obviously
exacerbated by the war in Ukraine we've
got to uh to react and so that will add
extra cost but Adam Bolton when he would
talk about the NHS he was a bit
disparaging about Liz talking about GP
appointments actually it's quite
important because obviously at the
pressures on the NHS tend to cup up on
in hospital beds and a e and part of
that is because people are presenting
themselves at a e because they can't get
into their own GP so it's actually
unblocking one of the uh blockages that
in the NHS to to help relieve hospitals
and other pressures there
yeah I know my point was though that you
know do you think something will have to
give with all this uh spending and will
Social care you mentioned the NHS will
Social care uh be one of those things
that get put back no I think look the
thing the thing is with Liz talking
about tax cuts looking at uh if you're
talking about reversing the corporation
tax that makes us more competitive that
makes people want to invest in the UK If
you're looking at some of the other
taxes she's been talking about that
helps entrepreneurship that helps um the
cost of businesses when you're looking
at things like business rates and and
other taxes that actually allow
businesses to start making a profit I.E
start make it start paying tax and that
in itself can add to the coffers within
the treasury which can then be spent on
public services
but she has obviously said she wants to
reverse the National Insurance uh hike
that was due in part to pay for social
care
um but she still says she's going to pay
for social care is that what you're
saying well that's what that is one of
the extra costs clearly because as I say
uh it's uh it's uh you know we know
there is extra cost what I'm saying that
not all of the tax cuts that she's uh
been talking about and and reverses are
are additional they you know some of
this is going to factor into the growth
and the additional taxes that come into
the treasury but the National Insurance
clearly will be an extra cost and
that'll be set out uh in the treasury
figures when the mini budget is uh is
announced
and just uh finally what about this
issue of uh party Unity uh what sort of
cabinet do you expect to be announced
this evening do you want a broad Church
cabinet
we want a cabinet that can deliver we
could want a cabinet that's got all the
talent to the the best of the talent in
there that can actually deliver for
people because that's what we'll be
judged on it's uh we've gone through
eight weeks uh with some people talking
about how popular each of the candidates
is going to be in September frankly it's
going to be how popular they're on two
years time and that will only be if Liz
and the government delivers and that's
what we've got to crack onto for now and
we need a cabinet that can actually do
that so it's all at the cabinet of all
the talents is what I'm looking for
okay Paul Scully thank you very much
indeed uh for joining us uh this evening
well Liz truss's Ascension was confirmed
after meeting with the queen she
traveled from Westminster to Balmoral by
plane and then by car after weather
conditions prevented a helicopter
Journey
she was then asked by the queen to form
a government and was officially
appointed as the new prime minister
well after her return to Downing Street
and her first national address the new
prime minister is now beginning to
appoint members of her new cabinet some
names have already of course been pretty
heavily trailed uh including her friend
and Ally Therese Coffey who has been
tipped to become Health secretary and
Deputy Prime Minister and who we saw out
here front and center as Liz truss made
her speech uh this evening and Sam
Coates our Deputy political editor is
with us and I mean seldom a prime
minister enters number 10 as prime
minister for the first time with so many
crises kind of crowding in on them
that's right Mark what was really
striking about Liz truss's remarks what
valley 25 minutes ago was that on the
one hand she paid fulsome tribute to
Boris Johnson saying he would he was a
consequential prime minister and then
she laid out how the Legacy that he has
left her is incredibly challenging how
she has some would argue the worst uh
most difficult job in 50 60 years she
talked about a pulling headwind she said
up front it wouldn't be easy and she
said as strong as the storm may be I
know the British people will get it uh
get us through it all of that in a sense
to manage uh in some way expectations
because I do think that I really do
think that she is having to lower some
expectations but then she set out three
simple priorities one to uh to deal with
energy costs another uh to boost the
economy and the third to look after the
NHS it's interesting how the NHS
priority has sort of come up the agenda
in recent weeks despite during the
middle of the campaign her suggesting
she might remove some of the funding
give it to social care uh now dealing
with the Health crisis appears to be one
of her uh priorities it just struck me
listening to her it's very simple speech
there wasn't a lot of rhetoric yes her
big tick you've got your uh or to quote
from Churchill with action this day but
otherwise it was Sean of the kind of a
baroque flummery that you sometimes sees
on see on these occasions perhaps from
Boris Johnson uh you saw quite a lot of
that but with Liz trust very simple
priorities the simple question is how on
Earth can she afford all of that because
you've got an energy package likely to
top 90 billion you've got tax cuts uh
that could top 60 billion you've got
markets who are pushing up the cost of
the British government borrowing up on a
sort of reaching new levels uh today and
you have questions about just where the
limit will be and whether if you borrow
that amount of money to help with
people's energy bills this year you'd
have to do it next year and the year
after if Putin is still fighting his
effectively his Cold War against Europe
which is the great unknown how long that
lasts and yet Paul Scully
um was just saying supporter of Liz
truss just seemed to be saying that yes
you know this spending is going to take
place yes I think I think there's an I
think the way in which Liz truss will
differ from her predecessors the way in
which she will in her words rip up the
treasury Orthodoxy do things differently
from the way that George Osborne or uh
Philip Hammond or or even
um Javid uh and uh and others uh Rishi
sunak have done it is that she will in
the first instance spend spend spend
it's a bit weird in some ways because
lizard trust stood for the Tory
leadership on a traditional small State
uh kind of low spending ticket and it
was on that that she was elected but in
order to get through the crisis and also
in order to do deliver the tax cuts that
she's putting at the heart of her plan
very controversial tax cuts many many
conservatives including lots of previous
conservative chancellors suggesting it
might be a bad idea because it'll cost a
lot of money possibly drive up inflation
she is just determined she made clear
today to press ahead with that it might
work
or it might cause problems fairly soon
down the track we're just gonna have to
wait and see all right Sam well let's
talk to uh Ian King our business uh
editor in the city because uh this is a
very important point that Sam coats is
making there Ian what do you make of the
spending plans that on the face of it uh
seem to be uh in we're in store I mean
in the first few weeks of this
government
well I can tell you what the financial
markets think of it Mark I mean Sam
coats gave you a flavor of it uh just
now but we've seen some very very
dramatic moves indeed this afternoon on
the guilt Market that's uh UK government
bonds UK government ious when the price
Falls the yield goes up and that's the
implied borrowing cost for the
government and I can tell you that we've
seen some real big Landmark moves for
example the 10-year guilt now the
10-year guilt actually has had its worst
one one month in August since 1986 the
yield Rose from 1.7 this afternoon it
hit 3.1 percent that's the first time
that's happened since July 2011.
likewise The Five-Year government guilt
well that yield hit its highest level
since February 2010 when of course the
Eurozone debt crisis was spilling over
it was just months before David Cameron
was elected at the head of the coalition
government pledging austerity to try and
bring down uh the deficit and restore
order to the public finances and then
the 30-year goat well that's also hit
its highest level it's March 2020 and
that's and for its biggest one-day daily
move so we've seen some really dramatic
moves on the guilt market and what that
tells you is that essentially investors
are looking for a higher premium in
order to take on the risk of lending to
the UK government why is that well it's
mainly because of this talk of this
massive package of relief that Liz truss
and her government are going to unveil
for households and businesses in
response to higher energy prices now
there was a lot of speculation in the
newspapers this morning that this was
going to be funded through some sort of
private sector effort getting the banks
to make loans to the energy companies
whereby they would freeze the price of
energy that would uh force them
effectively to trade it a loss so the
government would backstop that the
problem with it is that the susp that
that would be repaid over 15 years via a
levy effectively a tax increase well it
looks as though Liz truss and her
government have ruled that out they're
going to go for a straightforward
increase in government borrowing we've
heard that could be as much as 100
billion pounds and I think that's why
you're seeing this reaction in in the
guilt market now does it necessarily
mean that you're going to get a buyer
strike among investors that the market
will stop lending to the UK government
not necessarily if you look at overall
jet debt to GDP well the UK is pretty
much in line with uh some of our main
International peers the likes of the
United States and France I don't think
people necessarily casting doubt over
the government's ability to borrow in
the financial markets but what we've
seen this afternoon is that definitely
markets are somewhat wary of these big
spending pledges this big increase in
public borrowing that is implied by Liz
truss's package to support households
and businesses
okay Ian thanks very much indeed uh and
back to Sam coach just very briefly
because I understand uh
um this trust is no longer in here she's
gone to Parliament is that right that's
right the First Act not very long to do
all the security briefings she's gone
over to Parliament that's where you sack
people we are expecting some
particularly Rishi sunak supporters
Dominic Raab uh Steve Barkley uh uh alok
Sharma potentially uh could Now find
themselves out of government not really
surprised by the list of names of people
who'll be leaving government but
nevertheless potentially a painful
moment including for big Figures it's
interesting with Dominic Robb he was
another author of that Britannia
Unchained book alongside quasiquarting
and Liz trust uh uh back in the early
early 2000s uh he is the one person of
that group has been cast uh out uh
likely to be leaving government despite
being Deputy Prime Minister so that the
sackings is what's going on over in
Parliament across the road right and the
the hirings the sort of cabinet members
I mean they'll be coming up here do we
expect or do you think it'll be done by
own and get down to business what do you
think I think that the tradition of
having cabinet ministers walk up the
door to Turning Street will probably
continue uh but Liz trust will want to
do it pretty quickly because she's got
the list finalized all uh she's had it
almost finalized this morning so why not
just show that she's ready and organized
and can get on with the business of
delivering government by doing the cabin
at all this evening that's what we're
being told is is likely okay Sam stay
with us thanks very much indeed for that
uh so after five weeks of uh waiting for
the conservative leadership contest to
end people across the country will now
want to see action from Liz truss on the
biggest challenge of the moment the cost
of living we're now going to take you up
to Warrington and join Skies Chief north
of England correspondent